continue our special series kindness 101
with steve hartman that's where we share
stories that are built around themes of
kindness and character and the people
who have mastered those qualities this
morning's lesson is inclusion and steve
and his kids show us sometimes you don't
have to walk more than a few feet to put
yourself in somebody else's shoes
good morning this is my daughter meryl
hi and we welcome you to our lesson on
inclusion for definition let's turn to
our resident linguist emmett
inclusion is to not leave anyone out to
make sure that everyone is included
have you ever felt left out of anything
once in pre-k they were playing like
kitchen i think
and they
said they had enough people
it felt like
oh they don't want me i'm not good
enough
you ever had that feeling of it
yeah i have it doesn't feel good so you
guys know how painful that can be
fortunately inclusion is a weapon
against that and if you want to harness
this great power you turn to the master
of the craft
a young man whose story lives in our
archive of amazing americans categorized
under
inclusion
when the lunch bell rings at boca high
in boca raton florida 3 400 kids spill
into the courtyard and split into their
social groups
but not everyone gets included here at
boca high and at schools across the
country someone always
sits alone
it's not a good feeling like you're by
yourself and that's something i don't
want anybody to go through
dennis estemond is a haitian immigrant
when he came here in first grade he says
he felt isolated especially at lunch
now he's a senior he's popular but he
has not forgotten that first grade
feeling to me it's like if we don't try
and go make that change who's going to
do it
so with some friends dennis started a
club called we dine together we done
together we
we
died
their mission is to go into the
courtyard at lunchtime to make sure no
one is starving for company dennis i'm
here with you you're new here when did
you first come here for new kids
especially this is a godsend it's
gabriel gabe how you doing as a result
of the club
hundreds of friendships have formed some
very unlikely you're probably meeting
kids you never would meet on the
football team ever
gene max maridu actually quit the
football team gave up all the perks that
come with it just so he could spend more
time with this club i don't mind not
getting a football scholarship this is
what i really want to do
just imagine how different your teenage
years would have been what's your name
if the coolest kids in school all of a
sudden decided you mattered we get to
know each other better it obviously
takes a real devotion to inclusion to
spend your lunch like this
either that or first hand experience
i went from coming from a school that i
always had friends coming to where i had
nobody so
club member ali seeley transferred two
years ago she says with no one to sit
next to lunch
can be the most excruciating part of the
day see it's really unfair
it's honestly an issue
meeting someone who actually cares and
lists and listens to what you have to
say really makes a difference
and that could happen at lunch that
could happen at our club it's going to
make a difference i'll be around
tomorrow if you want to eat lunch
together or something
it's been almost five years since we
first told that story and i'm really
curious what dennis is up to now
hello dennis
hi steve good to see you again were you
able to open other chapters of we died
together
right now we are in over i believe 2 000
counties what started in a high school
cafeteria has swept the nation has
become a movement i know this is your
mission but is it also your job now
yeah so full-time since we last spoke c
i've really just been traveling and the
child that came to this country not
being able to speak the language has now
spoken all across the u.s the child that
couldn't even read or write is now in
the process of writing a book to help
people spread their own movements people
don't just get left out in high schools
they get left out in adult life too
are there lessons for those folks in
what you're teaching yeah steve i think
the issue of loneliness and social
isolation
is something that we will continue to
see
at every stage of life whether you are
16 or you're 60 we have a responsibility
to one another
you're changing a lot of lives and
helped a lot of kids so thank you so
much really appreciate it thank you
steve thank you so much
so i guess we need to always be on the
lookout for the lonely because sometimes
all it takes is a hello to make the
world a better place
and with that we say goodbye and don't
forget to stay kind
[Music]
we won't forget miss merrill we won't
forget i love how she always gives us
that charge at the end you know hello is
always a good opening but i don't know
any child who's sitting alone that wants
to be alone
even if they look like no problem i want
to do this but nobody wants to sit in
the lunch room i can recall the feelings
from high school now that happened to me
too a couple times on the occasion
yes yeah and steve said it best at the
end be on the lookout for the lonely and
you said you can't imagine a kid that
wants to be adults too and i know it's
hard for us to step outside our comfort
zone but maybe there's somebody who
passed by on the bus the subway maybe
having lunch that's sitting alone just
say hi if they say don't bother me i'm
eating a sandwich cool you can walk away
after that yes if you say hi you did
your job yeah yeah what a great piece
always pulling at the heart